[MUSIC PLAYING]
AARON ZEMACH: We're very
excited to welcome Jack.
He is the Artistic
Director for the Encores!
Concert Series at New York
City Center as well as
the Creative Director at
the Jujamcyn Theaters, which
include the Eugene O'Neill
Theater, where "Book of Mormon"
is currently showing, and the
Al Hirschfeld Theater, where
"Kinky Boots" is
currently showing.
And we're very excited
to welcome him here.
So, everyone, please
welcome Jack Viertel.
JACK VIERTEL: I'm
here in my snow boots.
So I'm not quite
at my most dapper.
Hello everybody.
Hello, Aaron.
AARON ZEMACH: Hi.
So, I guess from that
intro, I mentioned
you're the Artistic
Director for Encores!
And you're the Creative
Director at Jujamcyn.
But how would you
really describe
what you do as your jobs in
the theater in those roles?
JACK VIERTEL: It's
been a journey
of a bunch of different--
even though my job
title hasn't changed much,
a bunch of different things.
When I first-- well,
I started out life
as a theater critic for the
Los Angeles Herald Examiner
in the days when there were
still multiple newspapers
in cities like Los Angeles.
No longer true.
And then I became a dramaturg
at the Mark Taper Forum,
which is the big not-for-profit
theater in L.A. Sort
of the equivalent of the Lincoln
Center Theater or the Public
Theater.
And in that capacity, which
only lasted two years,
I worked with a lot
of young playwrights
working on and reworking
their material.
I wrote a lot of program notes.
I did sort of general literary
things around the theater.
And then I got hired to come
to Jujamcyn in 1987 at a time
when the theater--
you're all-- it's
interesting being--
I'm often the youngest
person in the room.
This is a day when I'm the
oldest person in the room.
I'm the oldest person in the
building, possibly the oldest
person on the block.
Back in 1987 and '88,
many Broadway theaters
were empty much of the time.
And Times Square
was this sort of,
to me, charming, but to other
people slightly scary hellhole.
And so we produced everything
that went into our theaters
ourselves because the typical
theater owner job, which
is to rent your
theaters to producers,
there were no plays to
put in the theaters.
So we made our own, basically.
And that went on for 10 or 15
years until the theater got--
sort of turned itself
around for a number
of kind of interesting
reasons that we
can talk about, if you want to.
And Times Square got
completely resuscitated
by Disney and the Times Square
Business Improvement District.
And suddenly there
were more shows
than there were theaters to
put them in, at which point
we stopped producing
pretty much.
And I became a handicapper.
I basically went around the
country and looked at shows,
came back home again, and
said to Rocco Landesman--
who was then my boss--
book this one,
don't book that one.
And that went on for a while.
And then in the
midst of all of that
I was hired to be the
Artistic Director of Encores!
Encores!
does-- if you haven't
seen one and you're
a musical theater nerd like
me, you might want to come.
We're actually doing a Cole
Porter show next week--
resuscitates these rarely
seen Broadway musicals--
usually rarely seen-- and
puts them on for seven
performances with
a full orchestra
and a full chorus and
a minimal production.
But you can hear what the show
sounded like in their day.
And the one we're
doing next week
is called "The New Yorkers"
and it's written by Cole Porter
and it was produced
in 1930, right
at the beginning of
the Great Depression
and in the dying
days of prohibition.
And, you know, if you
have a fascination
for what Broadway was
like back in that era,
it's an interesting thing to do.
It's been a very
successful series.
I've had really a great
time putting on shows
that I either
never saw, or shows
that I saw when I
was a little kid,
or shows that I'd
always wanted to see.
And my creative genes have
sort of moved over there.
And at Jujamcyn,
I've become more
of a sort of dramaturg for hire.
I get hired by producers
who are producing
new shows to join
the creative team
and sort of help them sort out
some of the dramatic issues
and musical issues
and other issues
that a new show tends to have.
And that also has
been very rewarding.
So it's a lot of different jobs
without a lot of different job
titles.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah.
And you've taken that history
and the breadth of knowledge
that you have about
theater and really put it
in this book, "The Secret
Life of the American Musical."
And you use this great analogy
that I love in the intro
that shows are both an
animal and a machine.
And you talk about how
this book is really
breaking apart the machine.
I wonder if you could
talk a little bit
about what you mean by that.
JACK VIERTEL: Yeah.
I mean the book came out
of a couple of classes
that I taught at NYU for almost
a decade about musical theater
structure.
And I think teaching the
classes grew out of the fact
that I had worked
on so many shows
that although I
don't think I had
any particular genius for it, I
had just learned a lot of stuff
about how you put
a show together.
And, you know, storytelling
has its mechanical aspects.
I mean, if you're a screenwriter
or a television writer
or a writer of plays or
musicals there's just--
if you want to hold the
audience's interest,
there are ways to do it.
And the more shows I
worked on, the more I
realized that the musical has
a kind of unique bunch of tools
in its tool box,
and therefore they
tend to tell their stories in
more or less the same ways.
But audiences aren't
even aware of that.
And so I wrote the book.
I taught the class
and then wrote
the book as a way
of sort of saying,
well, you know, this
is how we tell a story
on the stage with music.
And it's quite
different than how
you might want to tell
a story in a movie
or a novel or a television show.
It's not better.
It's just that we
have these tools
and we deploy them
in a certain way.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah, so
maybe let's talk about that
a little bit.
Let's say I come into the
theater to see a show.
I'm in my seat.
Lights go down.
The overture finishes.
And then you say
in the book the--
JACK VIERTEL:
You're lucky if you
have an overture these days.
AARON ZEMACH: Sure.
The overture finishes or
they've finished telling
me to turn off my cell phone.
And you say at this point
the audience is in trouble.
And the first thing
we're going to see
is them getting the audience
out of trouble, right?
JACK VIERTEL: Well, yeah.
I mean, this was a great quote
from a director named Michael
Blakemore about musicals.
He said, the minute
the curtain goes up,
the audience is in trouble.
And what he meant
by that was there's
so much information
coming at you,
and you have so little
knowledge of how
to detect what's important
and what's not important,
that it's the show's
responsibility to show you
who's the main character,
what era are we in,
what kind of show is this,
is it a comedy or a drama,
is it, you know,
romantic or dramatic?
And an opening number has to
accomplish all those goals.
Interestingly, the one
thing an opening number
doesn't have to do, although
some of them do it anyway,
is to tell you anything
about the plot at all
of what the show is.
But there are so many unanswered
questions when the curtain goes
up that a good opening number,
whether it involves everybody
in the cast or whether it's
simply one character walking
out and talking to
you or singing to you,
sort of is supposed
set your mind at ease.
OK, I get it.
We're in the
Oklahoma territories
at the turn of the century.
We're on a farm.
It's a romantic story.
All of that kind of
stuff it needs to get
taken care of in the first
two or three minutes.
If the audience is confused
about what kind of show it is,
they won't go there.
I mean, they just
won't get on the ride.
And if they don't get on
the ride at the beginning,
they probably won't
get on the ride at all.
So those opening numbers are
complicated to figure out.
And often I've found in
the shows I've worked on,
and also in a lot of
shows I've read about,
they are last thing written.
Usually the authors
write an opening number,
then they write the
rest of the show,
then they realize what the
rest of the show really is like
and what it's really about.
Then they throw out
the opening number
and write a new one to
support what they've written
after the opening number.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah, one of my
favorite anecdotes in the book
is you talk about
the opening number
to "A Funny Thing Happened
on the Way to the Forum."
JACK VIERTEL: Right.
AARON ZEMACH: And how
that got rewritten
and totally changed the
direction of the show.
JACK VIERTEL: Yeah.
It actually turned a
flop into-- one number
turned a flop into a hit.
I mean, it's an interesting--
you may all know this story,
but the show opened out of town.
It was a terrible disaster.
And my friend, Frank Rich-- who
was for a long time the theater
critic for the Times and now
writes for New York Magazine--
was a teenage ticket taker
in Washington back in 1962
and says vividly that he
remembers a matinee of "A Funny
Thing Happened on
the Way to the Forum"
trying out in which there
were 50 people sitting
in a 1,200-seat auditorium,
and how horrifying that was.
And Jerome Robbins, who
was a famous director
and choreographer and
sort of theater Yoda,
came down to look at the show
and said, well, the opening
number is all wrong.
The opening number is this
charming little number
called "Love Is In
the Air" and then
the show is this wild knockabout
farce slapstick, bad puns,
you know, whatever.
Said, it's not a charming show.
It's a funny, noisy show.
So write a funny, simple,
funny, noisy opening
number that says what
you're going to see
is a funny, noisy show.
And Stephen Sondheim wrote
"Comedy Tonight" out of town
and literally changed the
fortunes of the show overnight.
It went into the first
preview in New York
and the show went from
being a disastrous flop
to being a long running
hit and still revived today
all the time.
So opening numbers
can do that for you.
When they're wrong,
they really hurt you.
And when they're
right, they really
will carry you through
the first 15 or 20
minutes of a show because
the audience knows where
they are and they know
where they want to go,
where they're going to
be, and all of that.
AARON ZEMACH: And then
you say the next thing
that you're looking for
after the opening number is
the "wants" song of the show,
which you say it's the one
thing that no matter what, a
show typically needs to have
in order to be successful.
So what is it about
the story structure--
JACK VIERTEL: Yeah,
this is interesting.
Or I hope it's interesting.
Maybe it's not.
Musicals, unlike almost any
other form of storytelling
that I know of,
need to be powered
by somebody who desperately
wants to accomplish something.
That's not true of movies.
In movies-- movies
can-- there are
many, many successful movies
about some schlub walking down
the street and, you know,
something falls out of a window
and he finds himself transformed
back into the 19th century
or whatever.
And he has to cope.
Musicals can't be about
someone who just has to cope.
They almost always have to
be-- there are exceptions
to everything, I'm saying I want
to preface this little screed
by saying that--
there are some shows that
don't follow these rules.
But musicals are
almost always powered
by someone who wants
to achieve something,
passionately wants
to fight for it,
and is willing to
virtually die to get it.
And I think the reason
for that is that musicals
keep stopping and starting.
Musicals are locals.
And they stop for a song.
They stop for a scene change.
They stop for a costume change.
They bring in a subplot.
It's very hard for
the audience not
to get bored unless
there's somebody saying,
I am, you know,
Alexander Hamilton
and I have absolutely
no credibility.
I come from a small
island in the Caribbean.
I'm illegitimate.
And yet I'm going to fight
my way into this new country,
and turn it into a
country, and fight a war
to make it a country, and
nothing is going to stop me.
I mean, that is so--
you get on that ride.
You want to know--
is he gonna or not?
Even though we all know
that America happened.
We want to know how he
contributed to it happening
and how it almost didn't happen.
Absent that, there are very few
shows that actually succeed.
I can think of a handful.
But not many.
And so that song,
that "I want" song,
there are actually two
of them in "Hamilton,"
just so you get it.
The opening number
includes some,
and then there's "My Shot."
That opening song is
such a generic thing,
by which I don't mean it's
generic in the sense of it
being bad, but it's
a genre unto itself.
So you have "Wouldn't it
be Loverly" from "My Fair
Lady," and "Some People"
from "Gypsy," and "My Shot"
from "Hamilton," and
"Free" from "A Funny Thing
Happened on the Way
to the Forum," which
is a show about
someone who wants--
a slave who wants to be free.
They come in all different
sizes and styles.
But they always seem to
come somehow or other.
Even the abstract ones, like
the one from "West Side Story,"
"Something's Coming,
Something Good,"
which he doesn't
know what it is.
All he knows is he wants
to get out of this gang
and off of the streets
and into a better life.
And it's sort of
a brilliant song
because it's someone
yearning for something
and he has no name for it.
And yet, by the end
of the song, you
are following-- you know I'm
following that young man's
story.
That's where I'm
going to invest.
And it's a unique
musical theater thing.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah,
it's interesting to hear
that list you bring
up of all these shows,
from "My Fair Lady" to "West
Side Story" to "Hamilton."
And in the back, you talk
about how throughout the book
you quote lyrics from
"The Wedding Singer"
and know lyrics even
from "South Pacific."
So as you were going through
and looking for examples,
was there any rhyme or reason
for how you looked for, like,
what's the ideal
show to highlight
a "want" song or highlight
an opening number?
JACK VIERTEL: You know, I don't
think there is an ideal show.
But you find the ones--
I mean, when I was
teaching, I used
to find the ones that
were unequivocal.
And then use the
"West Side Story" one
as a way of saying, you
know, they can be equivocal,
but they still have to be there.
So a song like "Some
People" in "Gypsy,"
where Madame Rose
basically says,
I'm going to get my
kids out of here.
I'm going to turn them
into stars in vaudeville.
I know just how I'm going to
do it because I had a dream,
and here's what
was in the dream.
And all she's really doing is
asking her father to loan her
some money so she
can leave town.
And he doesn't want
to loan her any money.
But it sets up
this character who
you think is slightly
scary and somewhat
insane, but fascinating
nonetheless,
and is going on a journey.
And this is another
reality about--
it's really true of
any story, but it's
particularly true of
musical theater stories.
The harder the journey is,
and the more opposition
you're going to meet along
the way, the more interesting
it is.
Because that story--
any kind of story--
is essentially like an
athletic contest, right?
I mean, you go to
a baseball game
or you go to a football
game or a basketball game,
you want the
interesting characters,
the people with certain
kinds of virtuoso gifts.
But you also want to find out
who's going to win the game.
And this group of
people is going
to try to stop that group of
people from winning the game.
And a story is
kind of like that.
So when Madam Rose sets
out on this journey,
she wants to make her two small
children stars in vaudeville.
Vaudeville has not existed in
so many years that many of you
may not even know what it was.
But it was a kind of
touring variety show that
would go around the
country in the days
long before there
were sound movies or--
radio had been
invented, basically.
Although vaudeville
predates radio, as well.
So she wants to make her two
daughters-- who are, like,
seven and nine--
into kitty stars in vaudeville.
What she doesn't
seem to understand
is that they're not talented,
they're not interested--
one of them is kind of
interested, but not really,
and the other one is
completely not interested--
and vaudeville is a dying art
that's not going to be there
for very much longer.
So there's no way
for her to succeed
in getting what she wants.
But that's what
makes it interesting.
Because she won't stop.
If the story is milder, and
there's less going on in it,
we're less likely
to be interested.
When "The Wedding
Singer," which is--
I tell this story only
because poor "Wedding Singer,"
it was kind of charming,
hapless show that I worked on--
was in previews, and I
was teaching the class,
one of the producers said to
me, so how would you compare--
I mean, I know we're in trouble.
But how would you compare the
story of "The Wedding Singer"
to the story of "Gypsy"?
Because I had just given a
two-hour section on "Gypsy."
And I said, well, I said
"Gypsy" is about this woman who
has these two children
who aren't talented
and the business is dying.
And she's going to make them
stars anyway or die trying.
It's a great mountain to
watch someone try to climb.
"The Wedding Singer" is
about a wedding singer who
wants to be a wedding singer.
It's not about
anything, you know?
And so how do you--
what's the audience
watching, exactly?
And the producer was not
happy to hear me say that.
But, sadly, it turned
out to be true.
It's a very-- it's a show with a
lot of charming elements in it,
but it just doesn't--
it's not worth going on
that journey, you know?
Especially at $150 a ticket.
AARON ZEMACH: It's interesting,
thinking about "Gypsy,"
and even about vaudeville,
that in addition
to talking about all these
things that a show needs
to have to serve
the story, there's
also things like star
moments, and the main event
in the second act, and sort
of the spectacle pieces
that might not need
to serve the story
but are part of the
theater experience.
So I'm curious how you feel
like those play with the need
for a modern story
musical, and also this
need to go to the theater
and pay $150 for a ticket
and see some sort of
spectacle that I'm expecting?
JACK VIERTEL: I think
you want to see--
I think people go to the
theater to be engaged
by live entertainment
in a way that
is simply different from
watching a movie or a TV show.
And one of the--
or watching something on
your laptop or your iPad
or whatever.
One of the things about live
entertainment is it's live.
And it's actual people up there.
And so one of the
reasons you go is
to watch real people, just
like yourself but presumably
more talented, at
what they're doing.
You may have other talents.
Clear the hurdles, you know?
You want to see them--
can they do it?
Can Al Pacino play
Shylock, you know?
What's that going to be like?
And sometimes that's an
individual performer, a star
or person giving a
star performance,
even if they're
not a star, where
you're watching human
endeavor performed
by an actual human being.
It's a very-- that
also, in a way,
is like an athletic contest.
It's fun to watch someone hit
a home run or intercept a pass
and run 70 yards with a ball.
You want to see that live.
You want to be startled by what
the capacity for human behavior
is and the delivery
of human emotion.
And it's the reason
we laugh and cry
and we get excited
at the theater.
Sometimes, however,
that's also the spectacle
of what we can do on
a live stage, which
is so much less than you can
do in a movie or a television
show.
But it's real.
It's actually real.
I mean, the flying
monkeys in "Wicked"
may be on ropes
that you can see,
but nonetheless,
there are people
flying around the theater flying
around you in the theater.
And, you know, you get excited
by that stuff just because
of the humanness of it.
And I think as we get into a
more and more technologically
advanced world-- and there's
no way that that's ever going
to stop, we're on a, I
mean, unless humanity ends,
we're on a trajectory for more
and more invention in that
way--
the need to have contact with
human beings doing this stuff
gets bigger, not smaller.
And I think it's
one of the reasons
that the theater has
become more successful,
not less successful,
as we go along
this wave of
technological innovation.
We want to see those people.
AARON ZEMACH: Yeah.
For sure.
It's also really interesting to
hear you talk about your work
developing a new show.
I'm kind of curious beyond
the want, and for the want
of a show, when you're seeing
a new show for the first time
or reading the script
for the first time,
is there anything particular
that you zoom in on and say,
oh, this is a sign that
this is something special,
or oh, this is a sign that we
need to go into triage mode--
JACK VIERTEL: There's
a lot of things.
And I think that nothing
beats good material.
But what is good material?
Well, good material can just
be exciting on its own terms.
A great song or a great
speech or a great scene.
But good material,
really, when you're
talking about a musical--
and I've worked on a lot of
nonmusical plays as well,
but that's sort of
another subject--
when you're talking
about a musical that's
a story, as opposed
to something that's
just a collection of songs,
like Smokey Joe's Cafe
or whatever, if
you're really trying
to tell a story, what I
look for is, first of all,
are the characters outsized
and interesting enough
to hold my attention?
And is the problem
they're trying
to solve interesting enough?
I should have stopped with "The
Wedding Singer" on day one,
but I didn't.
And then does the story
get told all the way
through to a satisfying climax,
to where, at the end of it,
the audience will
feel, oh, I get it.
I know why I sat
here and watched this
because I got an
outcome that was
both inevitable and
surprising at the same time.
And it was worth it.
And it was worth it because
it made me feel things.
And it made me think things.
But all of that
is in the context
of a story that comes to
an end, in the same way
that kids like to have
bedtime stories that
have a good structure and
a good ending to them.
One of the things that is so
important in that process,
and I always look for it
when I'm reading a script,
is something that we call
the second to last scene
because it's the
second to last scene.
Sort of like
"Alice's Restaurant."
But anyway, there comes a moment
when everything pulls together.
And it's usually not
musicalized in a musical.
It's usually spoken, when
either the two main characters,
or in some way or
other two people--
it's almost always two--
get together and
look at each other
and they actually
treat the audience
to what was this all about?
Why did we do this?
Why did we have this fight?
Why was I trying to get this?
And did I get it or not?
And sometimes it
can be very direct.
The two I like to quote,
because one is direct
and the other is thematic, is at
the end of a very long argument
in a dressing room at
the end of "Gypsy,"
the mother finally gives up.
This mother, who has
pushed her children
and pushed her children and
pushed her children-- one
of them has run away and gotten
married and the other one
has become a stripper,
the most famous stripper
in the world, Gypsy Rose Lee.
And the mother is now-- who
was the most powerful character
in the show-- is now
stripped of all of her power
because Gypsy is so famous
and the mother is nobody.
And the mother says,
all right, I give up.
Basically, you win.
I just want to know one thing.
Everything that I
did for you kids,
all the ways I saved and
scrimped and sewed our costumes
and did everything, got us
from one town to another,
why did I do it?
And the daughter says, I
thought you did it for me.
And that's what
that show is about.
And in that moment, an audience
that's been watching the show,
thinking maybe it's
about show business
and maybe it's about family
and maybe it's about both,
you suddenly coalesce
around this idea
that this mother has done all
these things for her children
that she really was
doing for herself.
And her daughter has
just called her out
about it for the
first time and said,
I thought you were
doing it for me.
And it's like a big cymbal crash
at that moment in that show.
And the other one,
which is so different--
and the same, because it's
also a question and an answer--
is a thematic moment at the
end of "Fiddler on the Roof."
At the end of "Fiddler
on the Roof"--
and these are two characters who
are not important characters--
as everybody is planning to
leave Anatevka and this little
village is about to be destroyed
and disappear forever from
the face of the earth and this
little group of Jews is about
to go wandering across Russia,
out of Russia into wherever,
to America, to Palestine,
to wherever they're going,
one of the villagers turns
to the rabbi and says, rabbi,
all our lives we've been
waiting for the Messiah to come.
Wouldn't this be a good
time for him to come?
And the rabbi says, we'll have
to wait for him someplace else.
Now, that's not about the
story of "Fiddler on the Roof."
That's about the whole
history of the Jews.
And it lands with
an audience in a way
that they almost
gasp when he says it,
even though it's nothing.
It's a song cue, basically.
And they sing their
little Anatevka song.
But those moments,
when they work,
make you feel like you
know why you were there.
You were there to witness
something in human history
happening.
Or something in people's
emotional lives happening right
in front of your eyes.
And that's why we go, I think.
And in musicals, it's all
elevated because of music.
If there was no
music, we would just
talk to each other
like this, you
know, the way people talk
in an Arthur Miller play.
And, yes, the
language is elevated.
It's somewhat poetic.
And it's not really like
people chitchatting.
But it's still in
the realm of realism.
Musicals take it up from there.
That doesn't make them better.
It just makes it a different
way of telling you a story.
AARON ZEMACH: Awesome.
So in just a minute we're going
to open up the microphones
to Q&A from the audience.
So feel free to line up
for any question you've
ever had about Broadway theater
but have been afraid to ask.
JACK VIERTEL: Almost none
of which I can answer.
AARON ZEMACH: Before
we do that, though,
I just have one other question.
If you had to give
one piece of advice
to an aspiring Broadway
composer, Broadway librettist,
or book writer, what would
that piece of advice be?
JACK VIERTEL:
Interesting question.
I think in the
broadest sense, it
would be write about people
more interesting than yourself.
Don't write a musical
about what it's
like to get up in the
morning and go to work.
Write a musical
about somebody who,
even if they're a lower
middle class person who
gets up in the morning
and goes to work,
is in some way or other an
amazing and compelling figure.
Because if you don't
do that, you're
not using what music can do.
You're just wasting music.
Because music takes you
into that higher realm.
So write about-- when you
think about the great musicals
and who they're about,
they're almost never
about average Joes.
And when they are
and they succeed--
I always point to "Company"
as sort of the exception
to, well, so many
different rules--
when they succeed, it's
because of two things.
It's because the
basic subject matter
is compelling and interesting,
even if the characters are not
particularly so.
And the skill and inspiration
with which the work is done
is at such a high level that
you can't get out of its way.
It's just too brilliant
not to interest you.
But "Company"'s a
tough show because it's
about a average, everyday guy.
And it has always been
just marginally less
than completely
successful, even though it
was revolutionary in its time.
And I think that's why.
It's not about an
interesting person.
AARON ZEMACH: Sure.
So we've got some
questions over here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for coming.
You touched on this a
little bit in your talk,
but you mentioned
that in the 80s,
Broadway was not doing so good.
Right now it seems to me that
Broadway is doing pretty good.
First of all, is that true?
Is Broadway doing
well right now?
And second, if so, what
do you ascribe that to?
JACK VIERTEL: It's doing
very well right now.
But it's important to
distinguish between Broadway
as a business and each
individual show as a business.
The number of shows that
succeed versus the number that
fail probably hasn't
changed very much.
The ones that really
succeed run so much longer
than shows ever used to run
that they lift the numbers
and you can't find a
theater to go into.
There are no vacant theaters.
So, yes, it's a
very good business.
And the reason is tourism.
That's the big reason.
Someone asked somebody in a
talk like this a few years ago,
what's the most important
innovation in the theater
in your lifetime?
And he said, the jet airplane.
And, of course, it has nothing
to do with the theater.
There is so much wider an
audience coming to the theater
now than there was when I was
going to the theater in the 60s
or when I was working in
the theater in the 80s.
It's crazy.
And if you don't believe
me, just go to Times Square.
You'll never want
to go there again.
AARON ZEMACH: Over here.
AUDIENCE: I just
wanted to say thanks
for spreading the word about
the importance of the structure
underlying Broadway musicals.
I took BMI workshop
a couple of years ago
and it's like a small group
of folks who know this stuff
and remembered it and pass it on
from generation to generation.
And it just revolutionizes
the way you look at musicals.
I actually wanted to object
to the "Wedding Singer" stuff.
I think I saw that show because
it was free a couple of years
ago.
And I thought, oh no, this is
going to be terrible, wedding
singer, it was free.
I thought it was a great show.
It was a silly movie
and a silly, silly show,
but I thought everything
worked structurally
and the songs were charming.
So if you were involved in that,
then thank you for doing it.
JACK VIERTEL: Well,
I appreciate that.
It's almost the first
time anyone's ever
said anything nice about--
AUDIENCE: It was really good.
JACK VIERTEL: I
have to say that I
saw a workshop of "The
Wedding Singer" which
was a no sets, no costumes,
just people acting and dancing
and talking.
And I was very taken
with it, which is why
I came on board to work on it.
And it wasn't until I
was in the middle of it
that I realized that
for all its charms,
it never lifts itself
above a certain level.
And that just wasn't enough
for a high priced ticket
to a Broadway musical.
It just wasn't enough.
But thank you for
saying that about BMI.
I owe a lot to Lehman
Engel, who wrote
the first books about this stuff
and created the BMI workshop.
It's a great place to
learn all this stuff.
Then, of course, you have to--
once you understand
all the rules,
you have to figure out
how to break some of them
to write something
really original.
But it's good to know.
If you're going to
break rules, it's
always best to know what
they are, seems to me.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Julia.
I actually work
on the Google team
that helps Broadway advertise
on YouTube and Google.
So very happy that you're here.
I had a question about Encores!
because I think that
they're awesome.
I just went to, well, I guess,
a couple of years ago, "Violet."
And then transitioned
to Broadway.
So it made me think, you
know, as you were just
saying earlier, like
80% of Broadway shows
do not return their investment.
So people come out at
a loss financially.
And with Encores!
being that they for all
intents and purposes
are a full scale Broadway
show with the set
and the full orchestra, and
you get a lot of big names,
as well, how do you guys
make that work financially
if it's such a short period?
I know that some shows do end
up going to Broadway but most
of them don't.
JACK VIERTEL: Encores!
is a not-for-profit, like a
museum or a symphony orchestra
or a ballet company.
So we expect to get between 55%
and 60% of the cost of a show
back from the box office.
And the other
majority share comes
from foundations, corporations,
corporations like yourself,
and individual donors.
So it's a money--
from a commercial point of view,
it's a money losing business.
But like all of those
other institutions,
it's designed to be a
money losing business.
So you have to have financial
supporters who float the thing.
And because there's enough
of that, we're able to do it.
But it doesn't--
I mean, the shows that
move to Broadway--
and there have been
probably half a dozen
over the course of 24 years--
the only one that really
made a bunch of money
is "Chicago," which
continues to keep running
and continues to pay
royalties to Encores!,
among other royalty recipients.
But that's not ever
how we've figured
we were going to stay afloat.
We were going to
stay afloat from what
we call honored income, which
is income that's donated.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
You mentioned that overtures
are becoming scarce these days.
And that raised the
question in my mind
about where you think-- if you
think musicals are evolving
in structure or in music.
Because I was
thinking, you know,
you hear about
mold-breaking musicals
like "Book of Mormon"
or "Hamilton."
But to me, those are
still-- like, according
to the structures you
were talking about,
they still sort of fit that
mold a little bit, you know,
with the language.
And "Book of Mormon" might
be breaking the mold a bit
or that the music
in "Hamilton" might
be breaking the mold a bit.
But do you see, as
things have been
progressing over the
years, any changes in--
JACK VIERTEL: Oh, there
have been enormous changes
to music as well as to
the shows themselves.
Just to take them as slightly
separate issues, musically,
what's happened-- and the
reason I think you don't hear
overtures as much--
is that finally,
after, you know,
decades and decades and
decades of resisting,
Broadway has broken down.
And so what you're hearing
on Broadway, at least
in terms of orchestration
and arrangement,
is basically pop music.
It's not orchestral music.
And that's because,
you know, rock and roll
has been here for
60 or 70 years.
So it's about time.
But the result of that is a
couple of different results.
You don't hear overtures in
part because you don't really
have orchestras anymore.
You have bands.
And a band playing an
overture seems sort
of foolish somehow or other.
So you get these little preludes
and then the action starts.
Also, I think people--
and this is partly
Google's fault--
people are not actually
comfortable sitting
and listening to an
orchestra anymore.
If an orchestra starts playing,
they take out their iPhone
and check their email.
And so the purpose
of an overture,
which was to get you in the mood
for an evening in the theater,
is sort of something
old fashioned
that we don't really
quite believe in anymore.
The other thing
that's happened is--
it's a musical
question in a way,
but leaving aside the actual
question of music is--
shows like "American Idiot" and
others, like "School of Rock,"
I think are--
"School of Rock" is
somewhat more traditional.
But there are so many
elements of the rock concert
itself in them.
And rock concerts
became so theatrical,
in terms of lights
and smoke and sound
and costumes and everything,
that we're seeing
that line blur a little bit.
So the story musical
that really tells a story
all the way through is not the
only musical in town anymore.
I think the ones like
"American Idiot" that
can't decide whether
they're a story musical
or not tend to suffer.
And that show, which
got fabulous reviews
and didn't run nearly as
long as people predicted
it would, for an audience was
like, what is this exactly?
Am I listening to an album
or am I watching a story?
And if I'm watching a story,
why am I not interested
in these three characters?
Well, because we didn't make
them interesting enough,
you know?
But that's happening.
And what that evolution
will lead to, I don't know.
Musical theater is
always evolving, though.
I mean, if you look back to--
those of you who would dare--
to Sigmund Romberg and Rudolf
Friml all the operettas
of the first part
of the 20th century
and look at Rodgers
and Hammerstein,
or look at the
Gershwin shows and then
look at the Rodgers
and Hammerstein shows,
and look at the Sondheim shows
and look at what's followed.
"Rent."
Everything is
evolving all the time.
Even the earth is
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming.
This has been quite
educational, as I'm writing
my own musical outside of work.
But my question has to
do with ticket prices.
I was wondering what is
Broadway currently doing
and what should they do
better to include people
from different
socioeconomic backgrounds,
bringing them into
Broadway shows?
JACK VIERTEL: Well, there's
two questions, I think,
wrapped up in that question.
One is about pricing.
And the other is just about
outreach in some way or other.
In terms of pricing,
what we're seeing
is now that dynamic
pricing is really possible,
which I mean not only high
prices but prices that
change every other minute
like a stock market,
almost, you're seeing very,
very, very high prices,
which is a good news story.
But you're also seeing
steeply discounted prices,
assuming you don't want to
go to "Hamilton" tonight,
because there is inventory,
what we call inventory.
It's like the number of
seats on an airplane.
And, you know, if they're
not sold at a certain point,
they're not worth anything to
the producer or their show.
So you're seeing lotteries
and you're seeing--
it's harder to get cheaper
tickets than to get--
getting expensive
tickets is easy.
You pay a huge premium and
they'll bring the tickets
right to your door.
But if you're willing
to fight a little bit,
there actually are still ways
of getting into Broadway shows.
Not at a cheap price, but at
a price that a lot of people
can still afford.
In terms of outreach, I don't
think we do a very good job.
But I do think that the
not-for-profit theater does
a good job.
The theaters like the
Public and Lincoln Center
and all around the
country, places
like Center Stage in
Baltimore and the Arena
Stage in Washington,
they really feel
mission driven to do
outreach to different kinds
of cultural communities.
I wish we did more
of it than we do.
But we don't.
Part of the reason we don't, I
think, is that to some degree
because we're a commercial
business, everything
we do is driven toward
maximizing profits, which I
think is a sort of short view.
But nonetheless
that is the view.
Whereas not-for-profit theaters
are mission driven, rather than
profit driven.
And so they feel
part of their mission
is to get people into the
theater who have never
come to the theater before.
We do a little of that through
the theater development fund.
But not as much as we should.
AUDIENCE: I have, I guess,
more comments than questions.
I'm sorry that you mentioned
"Company," because as soon
as you talked about
the want driven show,
that was my first
counter-example.
But you stole that from me.
But I still think--
what happens in
that show, though,
is that the character
finds out what they want.
And I think the high point
of that show is being alive,
where they suddenly realize
that they did want something
all along.
Is that--
JACK VIERTEL: I'm sorry.
There's something like a
big noise behind me so I--
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
was saying that--
JACK VIERTEL: When you
got to the question part
I didn't hear it.
AUDIENCE: Well, in
"Company," it seems to me
that the character doesn't want
something from the beginning.
But they realize,
in being alive,
that they do want something.
JACK VIERTEL: Right.
AUDIENCE: That's
what you've been--
maybe that's what
pulls you along,
not that the character
has a definite want,
but that you see that maybe
he does want something that he
doesn't know that he wants.
JACK VIERTEL: Yeah.
I mean, it's a very--
look.
"Company"'s a very experimental
show in so many different ways.
It doesn't have a plot.
It has a series of
sketches, basically.
It's almost like a review.
The songs aren't actually
dynamic, emotional things
between characters.
They're comments.
They're, generally speaking,
commenting on the action
rather than being
part of the action.
It did so many things
so brilliantly.
And as a comment on American
marriage and New York,
it was so scabrous and
fearless that I think you
can't discount its brilliance.
And it does have an "I
want" song at the very end.
But for a lot of audiences
who were not cutting edge
audiences-- they were just Sam
and Rose from the Upper West
Side who wanted to
go to the theater--
they would rather have
been at something that had,
you know, they would
have preferred something
that delivered a more
traditional story in a more
traditional way.
But the reason I cite
"Company" in particular
is because Bobby,
that character,
is actually not a very
interesting character
for a very long
time in the show.
He finally comes
to a realization
at the end of the show
that makes it interesting
and makes you feel like
it was worth your time.
But, basically, what was
worth your time in "Company"
is the brilliance of
the actual material.
It doesn't deliver
satisfaction in the way
that a typical story
delivers satisfaction.
It has other elements
that are fascinating.
And, you know, it's one
of my favorite shows.
I don't mean to
put it down at all.
It just doesn't kick the
stone down the road in the way
that most shows do.
AUDIENCE: My second question
was about economics.
Wallace Shawn was just
here a week or two ago
talking about his new play,
which had a limited run.
And he said, you know, I'm
here, but in a week it's closed
and it's sold out.
So you can't see it.
And I said, can't
you extend the run?
And he said, the
economics now are
such that you can either
have a limited run
or you can go to Broadway, which
is prohibitively expensive.
Is that right?
Is there no Off-Broadway
extended run kind of--
JACK VIERTEL: There
is, but it's very rare.
And I don't know
too much about it
because it really has to do with
Off-Broadway show economics.
You know, what the
stagehands get paid
and what the theater rent
is and all that stuff,
which I know very little about.
I just know that in the
30 years I've been here,
I've watched commercial
Off-Broadway theater go from
being a thriving business
to being a completely--
it's like watching a
lake that gets polluted
and everything dies.
I mean, there's little
sprouts here and there.
But there's not much left.
And exactly why,
economically, I don't know.
You'd need to have an
Off-Broadway producer explain
it to you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JACK VIERTEL: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: So
I hate to do this,
but we have to end
a little early.
So I think we probably have time
for these last two questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Huge fan of Encores! and
a huge fan of Cole Porter,
so I'm very excited
for next week.
And on that note, I've
been hoping for many years
that Encores! would continue
to do Cole Porter stuff.
And so I'm curious--
and some of the other
things that we all have
things that we'd love to see--
I'm curious if you could talk
a little bit about how you
choose what to do at Encores!
after decades of choosing
things that are exactly
the right fit for it.
There are so many.
How do you pick
three every season?
JACK VIERTEL: We-- just to be
brief and then I think we can
deal with all the questions,
or both of the questions--
we pick a show
that we want to do.
And then we have to form
a season around that show,
because otherwise--
we do three shows.
If you can only
pick one, there's
no way to pick the other two.
So we start with something.
And then we figure, well,
what can we do around that?
You know, the problem
that we're facing is--
and this year the show we picked
was "The New Yorkers," which
we wanted to do.
And then the other two--
the idea is that the three
shows should be nothing alike
so that the audience doesn't
feel like they're seeing
the same thing three times.
The problem with Cole
Porter, and with all
of the greats from
that period is,
so we've now done the five
best Rodgers and Hart shows
and the four best Porter
shows and the four best
Gershwin shows.
So now you're down to
the fifth best, you know.
And it ain't that good,
to tell you the truth.
So what we're doing in
"The New Yorkers," which
is quite a lost show that
people don't really know, is
for the first time, because
some of the score was lost,
we're actually importing
a couple of good songs
from other Porter shows.
AUDIENCE: Which he
famously was supportive of.
JACK VIERTEL: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Cole
Porter loved that.
JACK VIERTEL: Yeah.
And they did it in the show.
They did it in "The New
Yorkers" originally.
They were throwing songs out and
putting them in and everything.
But we've never done it before.
We've always tried to be, like,
deeply academically faithful.
But we've thrown caution
to the winds this time.
AUDIENCE: Well,
thanks for doing it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JACK VIERTEL: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Big fan, of course.
I have sort of a silly question.
But I can ask you.
So I saw "Something Rotten."
And I just loved the song
that makes fun of musicals.
JACK VIERTEL: Of musicals, yes.
AUDIENCE: And I just wanted to
know your thought about that
and if there's
other musicals that
have done that in the past.
JACK VIERTEL: Well, there have,
particularly in the last 25
years or so, been musicals that
made fun of other musicals.
Or, at least, quoted
other musicals.
Or referenced other musicals.
I mean, "Follies" is nothing--
it's many things, but
among other things,
is a series of tributes to
other composers and lyricists.
And I think it's
a fun thing to do.
And "Mormon" does it.
I think "Mormon" does it
more brilliantly than anybody
because that "Little House of
Uncle Thomas" parody in act two
is just so--
whatever the hell it's called.
Joseph Smith American Moses.
It's one of the great, you
know, incredible things.
You know, my feeling
about "Something Rotten"
is it never got better
after that number.
And that was its
downfall in a way.
I mean, it ran a year
and a half or something,
but, you know, that number comes
about 20 minutes into act one
and nothing that good
ever happens again in it.
So you just have to get
through it, you know?
But it was enough fun.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JACK VIERTEL: Yeah.
AARON ZEMACH: Thanks,
everyone, for your questions.
I feel like everyone's going
to go buy tickets tonight, go
to Times Square, and
see a bunch of things
after being inspired by this.
And I'd like to thank
Jack Viertel one more
time for coming and
speaking with us.
JACK VIERTEL: I'm so
happy to have been here.
And I have to apologize
for having to run out.
But, you know, yesterday
was a snow day.
And so both yesterday and today
are happening to me today.
So I have to go do
something that I
was supposed to do yesterday.
But thank you all
for being here.
I really appreciate it.
AARON ZEMACH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]